hi I'm Chelsea and I'm James this is our
watermelon that we're gonna try to
explode using rubber bands and right now
we're at 90 rubber bands and we're going
we've somehow gotten talked into sitting
very closely to this and I'm nervous I'm
really scared so yeah we're gonna start
we're gonna eat this after this it's
good water don't worry
I don't like weight these water melons
these rubber bands break yeah I haven't
got slapped in the face yeah it hurts
we're told that this is gonna hold me
get I don't like this either I need a
drink you guys should have provided some
wine or something
100
although these outfits make me feel like
I'm in really Wonka
sorry this mate that made me like I
can't imagine what the watermelons gonna
be okay I think it's my nerves
these ones big bigger
I gotta get these ones they're bigger
eleven yeah I'm breaking a sweat suit
and at any one through college is
watching this guess is what I've paid to
get a degree
okay this is what I'm doing and I really
like it
I feel like I'm gonna get like a black
eye me too me too good like signal us
before she blows I guess we became
female yeah
40 yeah what happens if ever abandoned
yeah did they explode you guys are the
hate where you planning something over
there I don't like what's up yeah
there's like some producers planning
behind us yep I just I can't do a deal
with the ones that are gonna break
something for
1:49 you guys are tricking us it's
exploded I like 200 I know there's gonna
be like around yeah I'm sick of it yeah
we were told that it might take to 400
but I think we're being trimmed yeah we
definitely are I'm smarter than this
also if you're just tuning in we will be
eating this yes don't worry no
watermelon will be will be harmed but it
won't be
sighs they're doing - anytime oh maybe
you crazy
161
I feel like I'm gonna get so scared when
it explodes I'm gonna start I don't deal
with this kind of stuff but you know I
decided in yeah
oh sorry I like feel attached to this
watermelon at this point and now I'm
feeling gonna feel sad we have we really
have mostly it's my triceps thank you so
much for this work thank you yeah this
is like the actor on the doctor my yes
when I was like what 196 197 like I'm
gonna get walls into a false sense of
complacency yeah say my dresser 201 202
203
how many rubber bids I want to know
people at home how many rubber bits do
you think it's gonna take - yeah what
are the best bets better say it already
exploded some people are saying what are
we at yeah it looks like yeah and
where's the prize after this I mean I
know but even delicious water not come
on gotta give me more than a piece of
chicken perhaps I'm a little hungry
how your pictures yeah
good on fire or whatever these are now
she's more to win a war she's changing
secrets I appreciate this kind of stuff
imagine if they were like dude no Chuck
that's a lot of rubber bands
oh I could download it I'm sorry you
didn't want to participate in this
this is gonna be 250 you guys we're
halfway there what personal training
yeah I think how the elasticity
releasing oh thank you all right do you
think we work at like office now these
are these these are all right guesses
about what it's gonna explode yeah well
since you guys lied to us
I'm gonna say that it's 300 I think it's
gonna be 375 yeah surprises right rules
hey I don't see it yeah that's the Bob
Barker microphone for sure
that's better rubber bands why are you
guys all smiling and having a little
they're all under computer
no not again what the fear being here if
it was a gift the thing I have a huge
thing of red wine down season games 295
right
what is it you know what this is like
it's like jumpy Nicole cool there we go
there we go okay you know what we got
this dad feel invincible yeah people are
laughing at us
wait you guys Wow
maybe put a little music on
I went into my mom's Facebook and I made
her a fan of all our pages if you're
watching I love you don't worry we'll be
okay yeah I promise I'll go to grad
school see but you lose forever cuz
they're independent like us
I'm gonna be sad yeah yeah no no this is
like 320 oh yeah what are something we
tried that I'm sorry it hurt
what are the things that you like to
like hate to do but would rather be
doing yeah
yeah perfect
like three 21:42
this is tight
my guess oh you got I thought 375 so we
saw 25 more vans but according to you
guys that's too many
all right so let's count down 125 123
okay so we're at 360 361 sorry everyone
like you could do little things to make
things more manageable yeah like what
you're counting reps
yeah yeah yeah
stop it
I feel like I'm for good worldstar are
like World War 405 406 when we get to
420 I want someone to pass me for 1317
or 30 what if we did this with
scrunching 141 I guess you could make
double wrap yeah 70 but all of this
oh no I have a cup of numbering stuff I
one happens despite a lot of things I
don't know
there's stress in my body for 69
for 71 [ __ ] camper for 72 what if we
like what person in the conference room
was like you myself in this data for 77
what's the email like this like hey how
much do people get tortured in the
canteen
for anybody to make that truck 484 485
come on 491
496 498 499
we've both done 5:11 that's my breakfast
right 13 you guys live
there are 526 rubber bands on
thirty-five
I wouldn't know yeah
by 55 60 61 562 this is our 567 568 571
oh my god 5 72 574
576 517 778 579 okay honestly bye baby
bye baby one two three I gotta be
something by baby four maybe five maybe
seven maybe eight by nineteen ninety
five ninety three four and five ninety
five
yeah
yeah next time we should be like 612 636
646 16 17 6:18 and 16
six funny no six funny line it's on her
backside
6:24 what's going on she's really she's
filming
- okay 646 41
6:44 6:45 stop it fix 46 46 48 649 650
650 he's not too far for signs 652 653
654
there's no it's gonna week yeah
670 this is really bad 671 672 before
yeah something somebody I know yeah or
79
the final number